good morning Hank it's Tuesday so at the
end of every year I write myself two
letters one to the me from the past who
just survived the year and one to the me
from the future who's going to be living
in next year and I look at the successes
and failures and joys and heartbreaks of
the last year and then make goals for
next year this is the thing that was
suggested by my therapist and initially
I responded to it with the same
suspicion I reserved for all therapy
things but actually I found it
incredibly helpful because first it
offers an opportunity for reflection and
I feel like there aren't enough of those
in our culture right now it also gives
you an opportunity to think about what
from 2017 you want to bring into 2018
and what you want to leave behind so
today I thought I would write kind of an
open public version of that letter to
myself in the hopes of improving
accountability called leave it in 2017
all right listen up future me there's a
few things that current me is going to
recommend you leave behind in 2017
beginning with the feed you know what
I'm talking about the fact that you
spend hours every day passively
scrolling through information on the
internet that does not leave you better
informed or happier I'm not saying that
the social Internet is inherently good
or bad I'm saying that right now it's
bad for you so you're gonna leave it in
2017 at least for a few months until
your resolve begins to crack because the
social media algorithms have so
effectively hacked your dopamine
receptors slight tangent but the reason
your social media feeds aren't making
you happier or better informed is that
they're not trying to the algorithms are
designed to keep you scrolling to
maximize the amount of time you spend on
the site and ergo the number of ad
impressions you provide and the
algorithms are very good at doing that
but on the other hand John you have a
habit of believing that something save
the social Internet for instance is
going to be the solution to all of
humanity's problems and then when it
fails to deliver you have a habit of
over correcting and announcing that for
instance the social Internet is nothing
but a pile of burnt garbage but both
those extremes are equally invalid so
we're leaving those wild swings behind
in 2017 as well and instead embracing
something called nuance speaking of wild
swings let's talk about sports so sports
are great but with AFC Wimbledon
currently in the league one relegation
zone and Liverpool tossing away three
nil leads like Luke Skywalker chucking
lightsabers too much of your mental
well-being depends upon the sporting
endeavors of eleven mostly 20-something
strangers who live 5,000 miles away from
you I'm not saying don't care I'm saying
don't shout
everything is ruined all your dreams
will die at the television in front of
your children all right for more things
you're leaving in 2017 one prioritizing
your career over your sanity that's dumb
stop doing that secondly drinking more
than tuba croix per day I mean Lacroix
is great but show some restraint 3 being
snarky in the comments when you feel the
urge to provoke or to respond to
trolling or to meet hostility with
hostility just stop and lastly somewhat
related let's leave in 2017 the notion
that the avatar is the person and
instead try to remember that everyone we
encounter online and off is fighting
battles that we don't know about
now there's also lots I want to keep
from 2017 the life-changing magic of
regular exercise the value of real-life
events to celebrate usually virtual
communities and the reminders of why I
love not only writing but also sharing
my writing even if it's a smidge
terrifying I'd love to know in comments
what you're gonna hold on to from 2017
and also what you want to leave behind
Hank happy new year I will see you on
Friday